Tengo muchas ganas de resolver esta desigualdad,
fíjate bien, es una desigualdad cuadrática,
menos "x" que multiplica a
"2x" menos 14,
esto... esto es más grande o igual,
más grande o igual que 24...
que 24,
y tengo muchas ganas de resolver
esta expresión que tengo aquí, esta desigualdad,
porque se ve bastante interesante, pero,
creo que voy a esperar un poco a que tú intente resolver lo primero
y después,
veas si llegamos al mismo resultado.
Así que,
básate un poco en lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado
y te recomiendo que vas a llegar a un punto,
en donde tienes que pensar,
sobre lo que está diciendo la desigualdad.
Así que inténtalo
y ahorita le seguimos con este vídeo.
Muy bien, vamos a intentar
resolver esta desigualdad que tengo aquí,
así que lo primero que se me ocurre,
es multiplicar esta "x" por este "2x"
esta "-x" por este "2x"
y está "-x" por este -14
y vamos a llegar a que tenemos
a "-2x" cuadrada, ok,
menos por más es menos
y menos por menos es más... más...
"14x", ok...
Esto va a ser más grande
o igual que 24.
pero de una vez voy a pasar este 24
del otro lado de la desigualdad,
así que para pasarlo en el otro lado,
voy a restar 24 de ambos lados de la desigualdad,
recuerda que cuando
tú sumas o restas algo en una desigualdad,
la desigualdad se conserva, por lo tanto,
esto lo voy a pasar para acá y me va a quedar -24
ok, estoy restando 24 ambos lados la desigualdad,
esto va a ser mayor o igual que 0, de lujo,
aquí tengo mi desigualdad cuadrática.
Ahora, yo prefiero simplificar un poco los términos,
porque todo es divisible entre 2,
de hecho todo es divisible entre -2,
así que vamos a quitar este signo de aquí,
vamos a dividir todo entre -2,
para que sea mucho más fácil factorizar.
Yo en lo personal prefiero hacer esto
a factorizar esta expresión que tengo aquí,
así que dividamos todo entre -2.
Ahora, antes de hacerlo quiero que recuerdes algo muy importante.
Cuando nosotros dividimos o multiplicamos
una desigualdad por un valor negativo,
la desigualdad se voltea,
es decir, que ahorita que dividamos todo entre -2,
esta desigualdad se va a voltear,
en lugar de quedarme mayor o igual
me va a quedar menor o igual que 0,
así que vamos a hacerlo,
vamos a dividir todo entre -2
y me va a quedar,
-2 entre -2 es 1 por "x" cuadrada,
nos va a quedar "x" cuadrada, ok,
14 entre -2 me da -7,
recuerda que -2 es un valor negativo,
entonces me va a quedar "-7x",
lo único que hice fue más entre menos, menos,
14 entre 2 es 7,
aquí tengo -24 pero lo voy a dividir entre -2,
por lo tanto,
menos entre menos me da más,
24 entre 2, me da 12,
y justo aquí es lo más importante,
vamos a voltear la desigualdad,
porque estoy dividiendo toda la desigualdad,
toda la desigualdad por -2,
lo que haga de un lado de la desigualdad,
lo voy a hacer del otro ,
pero como -2 es un número negativo,
entonces aquí me va a quedar 0,
y la desigualdad se voltea, se cambia, ok.
Y ahora que tengo esta expresión de aquí,
creo que es mucho más fácil factorizarla, fíjate bien,
estoy buscando dos números cuya multiplicación,
cuyo producto sea 12,
y cuya suma o resta sea -7,
ahora, lo que quiero que veas,
es que 12 es un número positivo,
y -7 es un número negativo,
por lo tanto tiene que ser dos valores negativos,
porque si yo tomara dos valores positivos,
la suma nunca me va a dar un número negativo.
Por lo tanto me voy a fijar en dos números negativos
cuyo producto sea 12.
Y bueno 6 por 2...
6 por 2 = 12 no, no son esos,
12 por 1,
no, no, no...
3 por 4, ¡claro!
3 por 4,
si yo me tomo -3 y -4,
date cuenta que cuando los multiplico
menos por menos me da más, 3 por 4 es 12,
y cuando lo sumo
-3, -4 me da -7
y está de lujo, porque ahora sí puedo decir que esta expresión, va a quedar de la siguiente manera,
esto es lo mismo que "x" menos 3, ok,
es uno de los valores que obtuve al factorizar, ok,
esto que a su vez multiplica a "x" menos 4
a x menos 4, ok,
y esto también me salió de factorizar,
y esto tiene que ser menor o igual que 0.
De lujo, ahora, justo aquí es donde yo te decía que reflexionaras un poco sobre lo que dice la desigualdad.
Fíjate bien, la desigualdad me dice que un número,
que multiplica a otro número,
un valor que multiplica otro valor,
me da algo menor o igual que 0,
por lo tanto algún negativo.
y si yo tengo un valor, un número,
que multiplica a otro número, a otro valor,
que me dé algo negativo, forzosamente,
o el primero es positivo y el segundo es negativo,
o al revés,
el primero es negativo y el segundo es positivo,
no queda de otra.
Para que obtenga algo negativo, algo menor o igual que 0,
ó puede ser también 0, ó pueden ser 0,
estás de acuerdo, ok,
pero para que me dé algo menor o igual que 0,
no queda de otra,
o uno de los dos es 0,
o en su dado caso, deben de tener signos contrarios.
Uno debe ser positivo y el otro es negativo.
Así que pensemos que el primero,
para empezar, va a ser positivo,
y por lo tanto, el segundo...
déjame cambiar de color... el segundo va a ser negativo,
ok ,entonces vamos a ponerlo así.
En el primer caso,me voy a tomar a "x" menos 3...
y lo voy a poner con este color...
a "x" menos 3,
que sea un número positivo ó 0,
es decir, mayor o igual que 0, ok,
ya tengo un número que puede ser 0
ó es un número positivo,
y a su vez...
y a su vez,
me voy a tomar que "x" menos 4...
ah, déjame tomar el mismo color...
que "x" menos 4,
sea un número menor o igual a 0
pueden ser 0,
pero también puede ser menor que 0,
y recuerda que,
cuando tengo algo positivo por algo negativo,
me da algo negativo
y hasta aquí vamos bien,
bueno,
ya sea que pase esto...
o en su dado caso pase lo contrario,
y lo voy a poner con este mismo color...
o pase lo contrario y
¿qué es que pase lo contrario?
bueno, que "x" menos 3,
sea un número menor o igual que 0,
lo voy a poner cuando este color...
"x" menos 3 sea un número,
menor o igual que 0,
y también, que al mismo tiempo pase,
que "x" menos 4 sea un número mayor o igual que 0...
que "x" menos 4,
sea un número mayor o igual que 0,
son las dos opciones y no queda de otra,
o el primero es mayor o igual que 0
y el segundo menor o igual que 0
para obtener algún menor o igual que 0,
o en su dado caso,
el primero es menor o igual que 0,
el primero es negativo ó 0 y el segundo,
forzosamente tendría que ser mayor o igual que 0.
De lujo,
así que vamos a verificar,
qué es lo que me dicen estas dos expresiones,
vamos a trabajarlas por separado.
En la primera, si yo despejo de aquí a "x",
voy a obtener que "x" debe de ser mayor o igual que 3,
lo único que estoy haciendo sumando 3
de ambos lados de esta desigualdad,
que "x" sea mayor o igual que 3,
y a su vez...
y a su vez, también que pase que "x" sea...
que "x" sea menor o igual que 4.
Ok,
estoy buscando, los números, los valores,
para "x" que sean más grandes que 3
y que sean menores o iguales que 4,
¿y cuáles son éstas?
Bueno, pues si te fijas
son las "x" que están entre 3 y 4.
Es más, lo podremos escribir de la siguiente manera.
Son todas las "x"
que sean más grandes o iguales que 3...
más grandes o iguales que 3,
y a su vez,
sean más pequeñas o iguales que 4...
más pequeñas o iguales que 4.
Dicho de otra manera, las "x"
que están entre 3 y 4, tocando al 3 y tocando al 4.
Ok, bueno, esto por una parte, ahora vamos a fijarnos que me dice estas dos desigualdades de la derecha.
Yo lo que quiero en este caso,
es que "x" sea menor o igual que 3, ok,
lo único que hice,
fue sumar 3 de ambos lados de esta desigualdad,
y a su vez, que "x" sea más grande o igual,
"x" sea más grande o igual que 4.
Y en este momento me vas a decir, oye Sal,
pero esto no tiene nada de sentido,
yo no tengo ninguna "x"
que sean menor o igual que 3,
y a su vez que sea mayor o igual que 4,
no existe ninguna de ellas,
por lo tanto este caso es vacío,
no existe y no tiene solución,
si yo me fijo en este par de desigualdades,
no hay ningún número, ningún valor para "x",
que cumpla que sea a su vez,
más pequeño o igual que 3,
y a su vez, que sea
más grande o igual que 4, no existe ninguna.
Por lo tanto, este caso no es posible,
su solución es vacío o no existe "x"
que satisfagan estas dos igualdades simultáneamente,
recuerda que cuando tengo el "y",
tienen que pasar que estén en ambas,
aquí igual como tengo el "y" estoy buscando las "x"
que sean más grandes o iguales que 3,
y a su vez que sean
más pequeñas o iguales que 4,
y son estas aquí y de hecho,
ya tengo mi solución,
mi solución solamente son estas "x"
que son más grandes o iguales que 3,
y más chicas o iguales que 4,
es decir esto de aquí,
esto de aquí es mi solución,
de esta desigualdad...
de esta desigualdad con la que empezamos.
Y ahora lo podemos visualizar
en una recta numérica,
vamos a dibujar aquí una recta numérica,
imagínate que este es mi eje "x",
ahora déjame ponerlo aquí,
este es mi eje "x", ok,
y si por aquí tenemos al 0,
por aquí tenemos al 0,
ahora imagínate que aquí tengo al
1, al 2, al 3 y al 4.
este es el valor de 3, ok,
este es el valor de 4 ,
y mi conjunto solución, las "x" que satisfacen esta desigualdad, son las que están entre 3 y 4,
así que me voy a fijar en las "x"
que son más grandes que 3,
es decir, voy a poner aquí un circulito,
lo voy a rellenar,
porque si toca el 3, aquí tengo una desigualdad,
menor o igual
y no voy a fijar en las más grandes de 3...
las más grandes de 3,
ok, pero que a su vez sean más pequeñas que 4,
así que le paro por aquí
y me voy a fijar
en las que son más pequeñas que 4,
este si lo toca
porque es una desigualdad menor o igual
y las más pequeñas que 4, ok, todas estas
son mi conjunto solución las que están entre 3 y 4.
Y bueno,
ahora quiero que te des cuenta de lo siguiente,
este de aquí es mi conjunto solución,
de esta desigualdad cuadrática con la que empecé,
ahora quiero que te des cuenta muy muy padre,
si yo me tomo esta parte de aquí,
y la igualó a "y"
o me fijo en ella como una función,
si te das cuenta, esta parte de aquí,
sin contar la desigualdad, solamente esta parte de aquí,
es una parábola.
Y es una parábola que se ve
más o menos así,
es una parábola que abre hacia abajo
y que corta al eje de las "x"
precisamente en el valor de 3 y en el valor de 4,
se vería más o menos así,
una parábola que va a ir más o menos por aquí
y va a pasar por este punto,
después va a bajar, va a cruzar por aquí
y va a pasar por este otro punto.
Ahora, date cuenta, que aquí lo que estoy buscando
son las "x" que hay en esta función
más grande o igual que 0.
Y si nosotros nos damos cuenta
que aquí está el eje las yes,
si éste es el eje las yes,
ok, más o menos se ve así,
entonces los valores para "y" que son positivos,
que son más grandes o iguales que 0,
son entre estos valores de 3 y 4,
fíjate que son todos estos de aquí.
Estos son los posibles valores
que dan a esta función un valor positivo.
Ahora, tú me puedes decir
que lo podemos ver también con la otra parábola,
es decir, imagínate que quito todo esto,
todo esto,
y ahora me voy a fijar en ésta de aquí,
me voy a fijar en esta expresión que tengo aquí....
en esta expresión que tengo aquí...
De igual manera, si me fijo en el lado izquierdo
y lo pienso esto como una función,
te vas a dar cuenta que es una función
que representa una parábola,
pero en esta ocasión,
es una parábola que abre hacia arriba, porque tenemos
el término que está al lado de la "x" cuadrada,
positivo.
Por lo tanto, se vería más o menos así,
cruzaría al eje de las "x" en un valor de 3 y 4
y se vería más o menos, así.
Sería una parábola que pasaría por aquí...
que pasaría por acá...
y se abre más o menos así.
Ahora, quiero que te des cuenta, que esta parábola,
lo que me está diciendo esta desigualdad de aquí,
es que quiero que la función,
sea menor o igual que 0,
si este es el eje de las yes,
lo que estoy buscando es las yes, que satisfagan,
que sean menores o iguales que 0,
y si te das cuenta, en esta parábola,
las únicas yes,
que son menores iguales que 0, son curiosamente,
las que están entre 3 y 4,
estoy buscando las menores o iguales que 0,
y son todas las "x" estén entre 3 y 4,
que hacen que esta función sea negativa,
de lujo, ¿no?